the Hong Kong Court ruling opens up an
unpredictable new phase in the collapse
of ever
Grand foreign creditors filed the
petition a year and a half ago to force
the world's most indebted property
developer into liquidation and try to
recoup some of their losses ever Grand
was repeatedly given additional time to
come up with a restructuring proposal
but it failed to materialize and the
high court says enough is enough it's
been a very long and drawn out uh
restructuring and so enormous amount of
value has already been destroyed for the
bond holders the case now faces major
jurisdictional challenges in cases like
these foreign creditors prefer to go
through Hong Kong courts because of the
common law system and because of the
lack of transparency in legal process on
Mainland China but Liquidators have no
power to enforce the order from Hong
Kong courts on the mainland so all they
can do is try to attempt to grab assets
and sell assets that are offshore but
the majority of the value in this case
is onshore in China so there's very
little they can do analysts say
creditors are likely to recover less
than 5% of their investment and an
estimated 1 and a half million people in
China are left with unfinished homes
posing a serious risk of social
instability meanwhile Chinese Regulators
assuring up support for other struggling
developers and making it easier to
Access Loans as part of efforts to stem
a major Market Route it's unclear
whether the measures will have a
sustained effect at the end of the day
was still C due to implementation of the
commercial Banks and financial
institutions in China some of the
distress developers have not timely
received um the credit support where
whereas all the um additional liquidity
was subjected to the state owned
developers Chinese developers still face
the problem of sluggish consumer demand
the latest data shows house prices in
December fell the most in nearly 9 years
but analysts say ever Grand's fate shows
authorities are determined to bring
under control the property market bubble
Patrick ful Al jazer Hong
Kong make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer